[Music]
hi everyone i'm erica chong a partner
engineer at google cloud welcome back to
google cloud technical guides for
startups where we're creating a series
of videos for technical enablement to
help startups set up their own google
cloud platform environment and grow
their businesses successfully and
sustainably on google cloud this episode
focuses on setting up billing and alerts
and optimizing costs like google cloud
which i know is everyone's favorite
topic
the good news is google cloud makes
billing management and optimization
really easy
in this video we're going to cover
google cloud resources billing
administration
discounting and additional resources so
without any further ado let's get right
on into exploring the google cloud
platform together
if you're new to google cloud please
refer to video two of the series which
discusses google cloud resources
organizations and permissions these
concepts will be important when it comes
to billing administration
a billing admin is responsible for much
more than just making sure invoices get
paid they're also responsible for
managing payment instruments configuring
billing exports viewing cost information
and managing user roles on the billing
account the way cloud computing is
charged and billed it's a little the
shift in mindset from what most
companies are used to
instead of one and done data center
purchases billing is done monthly and is
consumption based managing costs becomes
a little bit different which we'll get
into when we discuss budgets and alerts
in order to connect a project to a
billing account you need to have the
correct permissions granted on both the
project and billing account levels the
minimum roles required include billing
account user on the billing account and
project billing manager on the project
or resource associated
higher permissions such as project owner
will work as well but are unnecessary
due to lease privilege design
while on the topic of permissions it's
important to note that when a new
billing account is created the user
creating it is usually also given the
payment profile admin role on the
payment profile
if you do need to change the billing
account admin role to someone else for
whatever reason remember to also change
the payment profile admin role
so what is a billing account
specifically a billing account is
essentially how you pay for projects
projects can exist without a billing
account thanks the free tier that many
google products have but you're limited
to quotas to fully operate a project
must have a billing account associated
to it a billing account is just where
costs and charges are bucketed and this
also represents a customer's legal
relationship with google the billing
account is then both a legal and
financial entity an organization can
parent a billing account but the
organization and contractual obligation
between google and the customer exists
at the billing account level
there are two types of billing accounts
there's invoice or offline and that just
refers to accounts that are invoiced on
net terms typically 30 days and have a
signed contract associated there's also
self-serve or online and that refers to
accounts that sign up in a self-service
manner with a credit card debit card or
bank transfer and are charged when
payment becomes due most organizations
will have a single billing account but
some may have multiple
generally if you have multiple it's due
to legal or accounting reasons or maybe
they need to pay in multiple currencies
something to keep in mind is that having
multiple billing accounts can mean
additional overhead and could make
things tricky to track and manage
depending on how many you have so just
be cognizant of that before you start
setting up multiple
a project can only be assigned to one
billing account but a billing account
can be tied to multiple projects a
billing account is managed through the
google cloud console
a billing account is specific to google
cloud resources but there is another
resource called a payments profile which
i mentioned earlier which is a general
google billing resource and applicable
for other services such as maps and ads
your billing account is linked to your
payment profile you can see and manage
everything at pay.google.com this is
essentially just a collection of payment
information such as mailing addresses
and forms of payments for the
organization as a whole
so let's take a look at what this looks
like in the console itself this is the
interface of a billing account the
billing id is at the top this is
automatically generated for you you have
your billing admin you can have multiple
here this person can add additional
admins and users and assign permissions
directly on the billing account
each project you create will be linked
to a billing account and here you can
also see which projects are linked to
that particular billing account when you
create a new project it will ask you
which billing account you'd like to
associate you can also suspend a project
to stop billing at any time
something to keep in mind is that
projects and billing accounts do not
necessarily need to be in the same
organization as long as a user has the
correct permissions to set up the
relationship between the billing account
and a project they could be anywhere so
you could manage things
cross-organizationally as well so now
that you have your resources and billing
accounts set up and running you may be
wondering how do i see what resources
i'm using and where are my largest costs
coming from
that's relatively easy and there are a
few ways that you can do this so first
you have your cloud console billing
reports these are going to give you
general information on your spend and
they're ready to go ready made examples
here
another option is your monthly invoice
this will show you details of
consumption associated with a billing
account depending on how many resources
you've consumed your bill could be quite
lengthy so it might be a lot to sift
through another option is to build a
customized billing dashboard in bigquery
data studio or a bi tool of your choice
this will give you more granular
reporting analysis and visibility and
allow you to really slice and dice your
data and derive insights from it
so let's take a look at an example of
one of these dashboards built in data
studio
so a data studio dashboard such as this
one can give you a more visual view of
your building
this dashboard has multiple different
views to give you different levels of
detail the first is going to be our gcp
cost summary we can see we have
year-to-date costs quarter-to-date costs
month-to-date costs we also see trends
month over month change in dollars you
can also add visuals such as pie charts
to allow you to easily slice and dice
your data and see how much of each
service is contributing to your overall
bill
you can also filter based on labels in
this particular dashboard we've added
granularity on the team
google cloud platform service and
environment levels
so environment could also just be
production and deployment
so let's take a look at our
costs by teamview so once this loads
we can see that we have four different
teams and with this we can get
granularity pretty easily so very
quickly i can see that almost 50 percent
of billing is by the pso team 33 is by
the engineering team and 16 is by the
networking team
over on the right hand side we also have
a trend analysis to which we can see how
our data is moving over a time
basis at the top we also have filters so
if i wanted to filter by date range
metric project or gcp service those are
options as well again slice and dice
your data
the same views can be seen on an
environment basis as well
these labels were created on the project
level and were included in the queries
used to export the data
so currently we only have one
environment it's production in this case
but we can very easily see that we've
accrued a cost of 827 dollars and same
thing as we saw before we have a graph
on the right hand side that shows our
trend analysis
this is actually a pre-made template
that you can reuse with your own billing
export data and there are instructions
on how to do so within the bottom tab
right here
next is managing our monthly spend so we
really want to remain on target to see
where we are and that's where budgets
and alerts come in so alerts are
important to avoid any sort of billing
surprises and you can set up multiple
alert percentages to get notifications
as usage continues to increase so for
example if i wanted to be notified when
i reached 50 75 and 90 of my budget i
can do so you can set notifications up
in your email or you can set them to
automatically take action using pub sub
cloud functions or cloud run this could
include shutting down a resource or
changing resource usage or sending
notifications to a ticketing system such
as servicenow there's also a forecast
trigger so this will allow you to be
notified as soon as you are forecasted
to reach a budget by the end of the
month this allows you to make changes to
lower your spend if needed and is a much
more proactive rather than reactive
response
so as mentioned when i showed that data
studio dashboard labels can help you
manage cloud applications at scale so
they offer clarity into resources being
used and can help deploy monitor and
manage at an individual application
level they can give visibility into
usage by department or group and help
with cost control and resource
management so we all love discounts and
optimization and here are just a few
ways to do so within your gcp
environments so cuts or committed use
discounts
allow users to pre-buy in bunk committed
use discounts are ideal for workloads
with predictable resource needs when you
purchase a committed use discount you
purchase compute engine resources such
as fee cpus memory gpus local ssds and
sole tenant nodes at a discounted price
in return for committing to paying for
those resources for one or three years
the discount is up to 57 for most
resources like machine types and gpus
the discount can also be up to a
whopping 70 for memory optimized machine
types
for cloud sql it's a little bit
different you commit to a consistent
amount of usage measured in dollars per
hour of equivalent on-demand spend for a
one or three year term in exchange you
receive a discounted rate on the
applicable usage your commitment covers
so you can purchase committed use
discounts from any cloud billing account
and the discount applies to any eligible
usage on projects paid for by that billy
account any sort of overages are then
charged at an on-demand rate
there's also sustained use discounts and
these are one of gcp's larger points of
differentiation so
this is basically a large discount on
compute engine resources for workloads
that are run for a significant portion
of the month
there's also preemptable vms and this is
another great way to lower costs if you
have workloads that are fault tolerant
and can withstand possible instance
preemptions discounts for these can be
up to 80
i suggest talking to your sales team to
see how you can optimize your
environment and really take advantage of
any applicable discounts so with that we
have tons of resources and guides around
setting up billing on our documentation
site i highly encourage you to take a
look prior to setting everything up in
your own environment should you run into
any issues our billing support team is
always available as well a couple of
resources have been added to the
description box below to help you
understand these concepts in further
detail so please check them out this
brings us to the end of the video where
we covered google cloud resources
billing admin discounting and additional
resources
stay tuned for all of the exciting
content that we have in store for you
and don't forget to like and subscribe
on our youtube channel click on the bell
icon to be notified each time a new
video is posted and we will see you very
soon in our next video thank you
[Music]
baby